يصبح الثثاني من يناير نقطه فاصله في مسار
الحرب التي تشنها اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
بمعنى ان الامور ستنفد من عقالها عقالها
ام ان اطراف الصراع سيكونون قادرين على
ضبط ايقاعه مره
اخرى نعم تحياتي استاذ محمود لك ولضيوفك
الكرام باعتقادي لكي نستطيع ان نجيب عن
هذا السؤال يجب ان نسال انفسنا هل
الاختيار اختيار الشخصيه والمكان كان
عشوائيا ام ان هنالك تداعيات اخرى اكبر من
ذلك يعني في نهايه المطاف عندما نتحدث عن
صالح العاروري هو قياض لحماس في داخل
الضفه الغربيه حماس
ال ال المتمكنه من القطاع يتم اغتياله في
داخل الضاحيه الجنوبيه في داخل لبنان يعني
عمليا اسرائيل استهدفت ثلاث قطاعات ثلاث
جبهات ارادت التصعيد مع ثلاث جبهات في ان
واحد هذا على صعيد الشخصيه ولكن كذلك
هنالك سؤال اخر يجب ان يطرح في في ذات
السياق وهو سياق المكان اسرائيل متوغل في
داخل القطاع منذ اكثر من 88 يوم تحديدا في
داخل ال 88 يوم كان لديها توغلات ميدانيه
بشكل يعني معمق المفروض هكذا حاولت ان
تسوق ذلك للشارع الاسرائيلي حاولت ان تسوق
انها مسيطره على كل ما يدور في داخل
الميدان بريا في داخل القطاع وعمليا لو
كانت تريد اغتيال مجرد شخصيه من شخصيات
حماس وم رياضت حماس من الصف الاول تحديدا
كان اسهل المفروض ان يكون ذلك اسهل عليها
او على الاقل حتى وان ارادت ان تصور جزئيه
النصر الحقيقي وليس مجرد صوره نصر كان
المفروض ان تسوق ذلك من داخل القطاع لان
في نهايه المطاف السابع من اكتوبر هو
جزئيه فشل استخباراتي في المقام الاول
السؤال الذي يطرح نفسه هل اسرائيل ما زالت
غير متمكنه استخ استخباراتيا من القطاع
هذا السؤال الاول السؤال الثاني لو كان
الجواب انها متمكنه استخباراتيا هل الجيش
العسكر غير قادر على تقديم
صوره اغتيال كهذه او كا اخرى من داخل
القطاع او السؤال هل لا يريد اصلا هل يعني
هو سؤال المقدره وسؤال الاراده على حد
سواء يجب ان يسال بالنسبه للجيش الذي سوق
في كثير من الاحيان صوره الارباك وبالتالي
نعود في الكره الاخرى الى المش الذي قال
به بنيامين نتنياهو بانه اوعز لرئيس
المساد بان يقوم بعمليات اغتيالات لقيادات
في حماس على ما يبدو ان هذه الصوره التي
اجمعت عليها اسرائيل لكي تخرج بصوره نصر
تستطيع تسويقها لداخل الشارع الاسرائيلي
وهي تعلم تبعيات ذلك باعتقادي الصوره ليست
عشوائيه في نهايه المطاف في نحن تتحدث هنا
عن تصعيد واسرائيل تتوقع هذا التصعيد على
المستوى الاستخباراتي الامني
الامال بان يكون تصعيد لتهدئه تاتي بعده
على المستوى السياسي على مستوى بنيامين
نتنياهو الامال بان يكون تصعيد يشمل يعني
المنطقه ويدخل المنطقه فيما اراده منذ
الاسبوع الاول حربا اقليميه الشخص الذي
ادخل اسرائيل في ازمه قياديه على مدار خمس
سنوات لن يابه بادخالها بازمه امنيه على
مدار سنوات قادمه اصلا لكي يلو بنفسه من
الفراغ